hey guys I think some of you might
remember my friend a day challenged me
last time to mix every kind of cookie
mix I could find together and this time
he's back on the internet again and he
challenged me to do the same thing but
with cereal which i think is kind of a
silly idea but one of my favorite
dessert places here in New York City is
normal fugu milk bar famously known for
their cereal soft-serve so I was
thinking it might be really cool to use
the cereal milk we make into ice cream
we have a lot of cereal here today so
let's get mixing we have Rice Krispies
Cocoa Krispies Apple Jacks Pops raisin
bran frosted flakes cornflakes I think
these are just special K original flakes
rice cereal mini frosted wheats Froot
Loops now for the bigger ones special
paper with the red berries Lucky Charms
honey nut cheerios whoa oh my god
cinnamon toast crunch there are some big
boxes coming my way where I know I don't
know if I can catch it
Oh Trix Captain Crunch strawberry yogurt
oohs cookie crisps foodie pebbles
Reese's puffs and honey bunches of oats
one more one more and oatmeal squares
okay give me two seconds to organize
this now it's organized this is going to
be a super multi flavored ice cream
let's start mixing them all together
okay we have all 22 types of cereal
lined up I'm probably gonna put a little
less than a cup of each type of cereal
into this giant tub after you put all
the cereal in I'm thinking of toasting
it a little bit in the oven just to
bring the flavors out and then we can go
from there
let's get pouring cereal it's good
pouring I'm just gonna do it first up
honey bunches of oats honey roasted
flavor cornflakes and
this cookie crisps I'm hoping that this
will give it that sort of cookies and
cream flavor taste a chocolate or
vanilla we have the cat move crunches
crunch berries I'm never happy before oh
yeah you definitely smell the berries
look at how colorful that is hopefully
that will add some color to our eye
space and then we have fruity pebbles I
just got a whiff of the super sweet
berry flavor onto this side we have Trix
tastes like fruit loops
it's definitely for kids and then we
have strawberry yogurt oohs I thought
yogurt was an interesting flavor to have
in your cereal oh look at this I'm
guessing this is strawberry a little
pink and then we have Reese's puffs
which I'm assuming is going to taste
just like they're Reese's Pieces wishes
peanut butter chocolate ooh
you can smell the peanut butter
instantly
and then we have brown sugar oatmeal
squares which I actually really love I
had this a lot as a kid super excited
about this this is only eight so far it
looks good though Apple Jacks I have not
had an Apple Jacks before smells like
cinnamon maybe you have to taste it I
only taste cinnamon
maybe that's the beauty of it oh these
are one cup sizes just corn flakes
playing as they are frosted flakes are
great art great is FA similar to corn
flakes but with rice through loops
oh it smells so good smells like
Candyland you know like when you walk
into a candy shop this is what it smells
like
okay I don't have to measure that
looking good so far let's see what we
have that is a lot of cereal and we have
pops
it's like sugar-coated popcorn to me
smells amazing then we have frosted
mini-wheats
extra fiber in your ice cream that's
healthy rice rice krispies snap crackle
pop Cocoa Krispies blue chocolate
chocolate
so excited about this Raisin Bran not a
reason and but gotta do what you gotta
do for your health this is gonna make it
taste like rum raisin ice cream without
the rum maybe we have 18 down that's so
much cereal you guys looks pretty though
last for cinnamon toast crunch
this is like a really nice snack Lucky
Charms got to get those marshmallow bits
ins add a bit of luck into the cereal
honey nut cheerios
I love these yes this is the last one
also my favorite
every morning love that they have
freeze-dried strawberries in here this
is it guys
22 types of cereal I'm curious to know
what it tastes like kind of a small
spoon super interesting I don't know
what I just ate I think I got some like
peanut butter in there it got the
berries in there so it's like sweet and
savory so what I'm gonna do now is to
pour this out on multiple baking trays
and then toast it a little bit in the
oven just to bring that flavor out and
then we can steep it in the milk this is
so going oh and you normally make ice
cream you need milk cream sugar and
vanilla maybe like a two-to-one ratio
for milk and cream and then eyeball the
vanilla so I probably put two whipping
creams there we go give it a good stir
I'm gonna add a little bit vanilla okay
you want to come try it yeah this is
what I've been waiting for all right go
for it
pink the milk to drink the milk to the
milk is the key part don't just get this
cereal and you fit that in one bite the
milk tastes extremely sweet I think it's
a good thing we don't appreciate it
exactly
I really taste the fruity pebbles the
most the pre prevalent in the front of
the crowd there the leader of the pack I
can't wait to see if you come up with
right now we taste that sweetness but
the flavor of the cereals aren't really
there yet I think what we're gonna do is
set this aside let it steep for an hour
and then after that we can pop it in the
ice cream machine I'm gonna put the lid
on this but
frig be back in an hour bye-bye we're
back with our cereal milk I'm kind of
surprised I was expecting more color
there's little less liquid now I think
because this cereal really soaked it up
but I think we have more than enough to
get us a good batch of ice cream I'm
gonna strain this now so we can get all
the cereal bits out and leave just the
milk I'm just gonna press down on this
to really get that liquid out the
texture is super creamy still smells
amazing I'm just gonna taste this a
little bit it's surprisingly sweet for
the zero amount of sugar we put into
this if I means that there's a lot of
sugar and the cereal we normally you
think this is ready to go into the ice
cream machine I've never used an ice
cream machine before so I hope I don't
mess this up I have two cups of the
cereal milk here gonna pour I think four
cups maybe I'm gonna turn this on and
I'm gonna pour this in a bowl
nervous I can see little cereal bits
floating in here I'm just gonna let it
do its thing hopefully we'll have ice
cream then the ice cream machine has
been going at it for around 25 to 30
minutes I think so I'm thinking I might
scoop this out oh yeah look at that it's
so creamy I'm just really curious I'm
gonna try a little bit it's really good
it is sweet but it's a very subtle
sweetness I think I'm tasting the food
enos from the foodie pebbles textures
super creamy and also reminds me of just
like the texture of old milk so you get
that sort of like thick and a little bit
grainy consistency which is not
unpleasant at all so into this and goes
so I skipped all of it out I think we
have around maybe two pints of ice cream
here I'm going to wrap it up now and
we're gonna put it back in the freezer
check on it and maybe two hours or so
and then we can scoop and serve we have
the meson class here 22 types of cereal
let's get scooping and make this little
pretty the reason we didn't put any of
the toppings in the ice cream was
because I was worried that it would
overwhelm the flavor I'm gonna throw on
these little toppings and people can
choose how much they want from a normal
bowl of cereal with milk transformed
into cereal milk ice cream with 22
different kinds of cereal toppings I
guess now it's time for the ultimate
taste test with a day
[Music]
this is really good so many flavors
there's like hints of like chocolate
there's fruit I think this is gonna be
like the new wave of the summer summer
2019 it's all about Incas ice cream
event run it there should be a cool way
to eat cereal because it is still milk
essentially right it's like milk and
cream this way it won't get soggy oh my
god the best thing about this no soggy
cereal coming to a bowl near you that
was so elated I don't know what you do
next maybe mixing all ice creams
together since you're so good at this
hey screams - I don't know what do you
guys think let get know in the comments
she'll make some ice cream she'll make
oh how many could you do this tons of
items you can do